is the pride of McKinney Texas made its
bones right here in South Central Los
Angeles playing for USC football for
years here in Southern California and he
trails as he enters the National
Football League in terms of most rushing
yards in school history only Ricky Bell
Anthony Davis Marcus Allen and Charles
white he is Ronald Jones good to see you
sir good to see you think you better
better for having you here thanks for
being here really appreciate that all
right let's get right into this thing
with you who have you spoken to who have
you personally spoken to in the National
Football League oh okay yeah well no no
op teams
yeah so I just got back from
Philadelphia you just got back from
Philly yeah you visited Philadelphia
Philadelphia the Ravens Patriots
Buccaneers Colts 49ers Redskins and I'll
say Raven o Cowboys as well Cowboys
yes see what you did you meet with Jerry
I did not uh he was a little busy - he
was a little busy there okay
did you meet with Belichick when you
were in I do I do what was that
conversation well you know the media
portrays him you know to be honest you
know uptight and guy but he was smiling
you know laughing and joking with us
prospects so you know that was fun so it
was more than just you meeting with so
who are you with with him I was with
Kari on Johnson and Kaitlyn balázs so it
was just a a group meeting with them
yeah okay did you glean anything from
any team that I think this team wants me
more than any other teams yeah I mean
all of them you know they were great you
know just about the same process you
know meeting the staff the players
director personnel a lot of stuff mmm
about a spoon so which players then I
guess have you reached out to chatted
with anybody in the NFL ready for this
process Ronald yeah Nelson
Aguila Rob just you know hit him up ask
him how working minicamp OTAs what did
they tell you about it uh they say once
you get to training camp you know the
season the practices are actually easier
than oil Congress law huh
yeah surprisingly so did Nelson show you
the hardware yet okay yeah I wanna see
that though and juju Smith Shuster did
he
did he you know show you the bicycle did
you do Smith's Shuster bicycle he never
found a bike man that's a sad any give
it back though okay so so let me get
into this too now your teammates and
Arnold may be number one overall oh yeah
now walk me through what you did to have
him throw to you at your makeup Pro day
here in Los Angeles a couple weeks ago
yes so uh you know we we knew he was
taking that visit or whatever and then I
had my agent reach out to his agent and
you know they just communicated in him
he showed up that day you know right off
the plane from Cleveland and you know he
was through for me so so at 7:00 a.m. in
the morning yeah he was there you know
brightener like it was his pro day and
you know that's just you know accredit
to him and the guy he is and that he's
always been for us and another teammate
so how good of it
tell me about his teammate gene that he
has in his football body well yeah he's
gonna make uh you know all the players
around him better you know he's gonna
elevate their game in like me you know
we calm them in each other you don't
need to do it to a quarterback so he's
gotten all too smooth and you're a dual
threat running back I am okay God are
you and how is he in the huddle on the
huddle uh you know depends on situation
no he's pretty quiet uh but you know
we're down and you know we need to make
a play you know first down things like
that you know he's gonna get onto you
okay the guys this point so pound the
table for you of Ronald Jones here on
the Rich Eisen show pound the table for
yourself here because all I'm hearing
about is sake 1mm pound the table for
yourself here as to what what you could
do in the NFL oh yeah well you know I'm
in every down back you know a speed
vision you know power you know I can
catch out of the backfield
step up you know we need to to the block
so uh yeah I'm just looking forward to
you know that next chapter I'm ready to
get started well you know what do you
need to be in the NFL to be a third down
back right yes sir and that is hands and
all you got a passport alia protection
that's it it's QC I kind of just put you
on the board right there yeah in a way
well I mean how do you rate your ability
to do something like that already pretty
high by like nineteen nine out of ten I
just you know technique you know you can
always use improvement okay but yeah
that jump you know to the next level
when you're in your dream scenario where
do you end up
dream scenario you know what every team
calls my name so you know it's been a
blessing you know this whole process and
just had that moment finally come you
know is gonna be the world to be I I
hear you but being someone from Texas
mm-hmm is were you a Cowboy fan growing
up oh yeah most definitely yeah growing
up you know my father
you know rooting for the Cowboys my
grandpa mom so yeah I went to Cowboys
games when I was little I saw my Julius
Jones played those guys so definitely
yeah but you know now I'm neutral so of
course now I know you're neutral but I
mean walking into a Dallas Cowboy
facility mm-hmm with the possibility of
being drafted by them yeah was that any
special meaning for you most definitely
you know especially since I just moved
the facilities to Frisco risco which is
like 15 minutes away from my house so
when I pull it up you know it was
everything you know I thought it'd be
hmm but they have Zeke there yeah they
do have interesting dude I got a they
got a nice butt in Philly in Philly also
they have a nice it seems rotation of
running backs to you that you could you
could work your way into right there
you know that's entire possibility yeah
so when it all comes down to it you know
what was the most what has been the most
challenging part about this process for
you yeah definitely dealing with the
hamstring you know it's been a nagging
injury originally herded back you know
around Valentine's Day and then tried to
come back you know for our pro day you
know I still wasn't ready to go and then
try to you know that's why I had this
have the second pro day where Sam came
back and you know it's just been bugging
me you know this whole time I'd had it
in college or high school so I didn't
know that'll recovery time on it's the
first hamstring injury you've ever had
yes sir
and it happened at the combine that's
what I'm saying like the one time where
you need it the most so that was
definitely frustrating okay and in terms
of just trying to figure out where you
might wind up yeah now that part's
exciting you know everybody calls it
recruiting but you know you don't get to
choice so having all those trips you
know that was fun you know
being on in all those different cities
right but uh yeah was that we can see
are you going to the draft no sir I'll
be at home you know the Jazz about 30
minutes for miles oh yeah I'm gonna have
something that my friends local barber
restaurant we're just friends of him
okay you want to give a shout out to the
barbecue rest oh yeah Hudson's barbecue
man in McKinney Texas uh so Frisco well
what's on them so you you're right there
oh yeah right there
yeah you're right there I'm gonna get a
chopped beef you know is what it is with
each other what's on the menu they got
everything they got ribs turkey green
beans sweet potato pie and so when you
when you go there you get to order the
food that you want right oh yeah yeah
all you got to do the sign-off so okay
you're taking like six bags ago you know
pounds of brisket what if you had a
draft party where you invited everybody
in but you had like a fantasy draft for
the type of food that would be on the
menu oh where where basically you don't
get to order what you want you have a
draft position and you draft the food
off the board would you do something
like that
uh yeah that might be a little too
complicated because what we gonna made
turkey like is that turkey quarterback
or ya know well I asked the guy with his
burger draft to celebrate his birthday
you didn't think I'd go down this
wormhole at all with me why are you
using this valuable Ronald Jones real
estate burger draft man I was gonna say
do you plus two for that draft partly
because the barbecue sounds amazing
oh yeah this is the best buy Texas
before y'all come out to the job you
know please be careful no I'll be on the
air I've gotta be real show up well I'll
give a shout out you know cuz I'm sure
we'll have a camera or something at your
draft party or just like that it well
and what was the most bizarre question
you were asked at the Scouting Combine
yeah I came through you know pretty
luckily uh
you know 50% about football 50% you know
background so the winter saying they
asked me to know why did you cut your
dress after my freshman year I cut him
you know that I grew him back and in
alman process of growing the back again
slow his ass is like are you keeping
them with like what what's up with there
so it wasn't too bad I got lucky
so why all right what was the answer you
actually gave like I just felt like
cutting it yeah pretty much
you know I didn't have my lady who did
it all through high school out here so I
couldn't see her you know I was only go
home three or four times a year so
that I could never let them please go
and do you think the running back
position is valued properly in the NFL
because say Quan is only the outlier
here st. going top five top ten top 15
almost definitely yeah I mean if you
look at teams like the Cowboys uh what
Fernet you know differ his team Kamara
and hunt you know but definitely you
know getting respect back for the
position and you know it's good for us
and all of us newcomers okay
well I hope you get drafted as high as
you possibly want yes the last one for
you uh and the hair front now I know
you're big fan of Sam darn 'old for good
reason
we saw his pro day where he threw in the
rain oh okay but he put a hat on to
protect the elite quarterback hair and
we thought that was a red flag what do
you think I'm mad to disagree which is
he has you know well I'm pretty sure was
right it's right there and the TV
alright it was okay with the hoops so
you were there the day that it was
raining yeah okay it raining like right
before my position Jerusalem but I
notice you didn't I notice you didn't
put on a hat then you didn't have long
sleeves either it's hard to where it has
these days which is okay all right way
to be a teammate yes Alicia ate that all
right Ronald will see out there in uh in
in Texas good luck to you I usually you
bet and when you start scoring
touchdowns you come on back on this show
oh yeah I got you you got very good
Ronald Jones at row Joe on Twitter came
out it follow that how many followers
you have right now on Twitter yeah I
like to take ages okay just wait I don't
like tweeting but i'ma start you have to
dig out soon come on now it's your brand
is Twitter
it's your brand tweet okay Ronald Jones
here on the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience